[Musica]
nato a brescia all'ospedale
fatebenefratelli
proprio nel centro storico della nostra
città in una domenica mattina di fine
maggio nel 1967
l'ostetrica di disse a mia madre sarà
molto pigro perché quelli che nascono di
domenica solitamente sono pigri e anche
affamato perché in effetti ero nato
all'ora di pranzo i vaticini
dall'ostetrica si sono avverati in in
gran parte
ed allora amo pensare che quel giorno
mentre io uscivo dal corpo di mia madre
i beatles uscivano in tutto il mondo con
il loro uno dei loro capolavori sergeant
pepper's lonely hearts club band
un disco che cambiò in qualche modo le
sorti della musica rock ma soprattutto
un disco pieno di quelle emozioni che
poi chissà come per magia forse o perché
respiravo l'energia che c'era in quel
mondo in quel momento parlava di
psichedelìa di pace c'era la
controcultura hippy c'era tutte quelle
quei concetti che poi diventerebbero
diventeranno cari anche a quello a quel
bambino appena nato
la mia famiglia veniva dal lago di garda
anche se in realtà le origini della
famiglia migliora passano della
franciacorta e la mamma ha un po di
sangue mantovane un po veronese però si
trovarono tutti sotto lo stesso tetto i
miei bisnonni i miei nonni e poi anche i
miei genitori sotto il tetto del
cotonificio olcese di campione del garda
sul lago di garda dove era stato
costruito questo enorme stabilimento
tessile e appunto tutti gli abitanti
avevano scritto nel loro destino che
sarebbero diventati impiegati operai
dello stesso cotonificio il direttore il
dottor olcese era uno di quegli
imprenditori illuminati come diremmo più
tardi anche ad altri
adattandolo ad altri imprenditori
pensiamo olivetti o altri più celebri e
quindi dava ad ogni operaio sebbene
fossero tutte famiglie piuttosto povere
un piccolo orto e un appartamento dove
vivere questo fece scatenare la corsa al
lavoro che in quegli anni siamo gli
italianisti del novecento c'era mia
madre mia madre entrò in cotonificio a
10 anni e un giorno
so che a dirlo oggi è pensando poi che
fosse una bambina e fa un po impressione
però allora si poteva la nonna chiese un
permesso speciale per farla andare a
lavorare a dieci anni perché aveva
bisogno del suo aiuto per dare da
mangiare agli altri due figli dei
fratellini dalla mamma
la strapperà al suo destino tredici anni
dopo a 23 anni il mio papà mio papà
roberto che essendo molto molto bravo a
scuola negli studi aveva dimostrato
delle capacità fuori del normale e come
tutti i figli degli operai più
meritevoli il direttore gli aveva dato
la possibilità di studiare questa è la
prima ricchezza che fu offerta al mio
papà è addirittura lo mandarono a riva
del garda in collegio dove si iscrisse
al liceo ginnasio di riva del garda
quando ha preso il suo diploma
prima ci prova con l'università ma i
soldi in famiglia non gli permettevano
di studiare allora decise di cambiare il
suo destino con questo è la prima il
primo esempio di reazione di react che
ho avuto nella mia vita
passò dal cotonificio prese la mamma la
fece licenziare e attraverso il lago ed
arrivo a brescia dove appunto in quella
domenica di fine maggio
sono arrivato io quel pezzo di carta era
un diploma classico in fin dei conti un
diploma di liceo ma che valeva credo
come una buona laurea oggi se facciamo i
debiti paragoni
arrivati qua i soldini erano veramente
pochi quindi io e la mia sorellina che
arriverà a due anni dopo cresciamo a
urago mella un quartiere che oggi è un
quartiere anche simpatico multietnico
abbastanza vivo
allora oltremella chi ha più di 40 anni
45 probabilmente se lo ricorda bene era
un po un sul ponte del mella c'era un
hicks sunt leones in qualche modo era un
punto pericoloso da oltrepassare per che
lungo il mella chiedetelo ai vostri
genitori se siete bresciani c'era un
addirittura delle barre delle baracche
una baraccopoli che era pro toccando il
mio asilo e allora il comune costruire
le case popolari dove convogliarono
famiglie delle zone limitrofe come la
mia che erano a brescia in cerca di
fortuna ricerca di lavoro e tutti i
figli di quelli che noi con sicuramente
poca sensibilità e intelligenza
chiamavamo i figli degli sfrattati e poi
ci ritrovavamo tutti a scuola quindi
sono cresciuto in un quartiere
fortemente popolare dove dove però ho
imparato alcune alcuni dei concetti
alcuni dei valori che difficilmente si
imparano altrove quindi sono grato al
destino di avermi fatto crescere così e
poi papa
parallelamente stava cominciando andare
bene col lavoro tant'è che si parlava in
famiglia quando io ero ancora alle
elementari di aprirsi la sua officina a
urago mella ho imparato a reagire mi
insegnavano i più grandi ma lo capivi
già alle medie perché c'era sempre
qualcuno che cercava di rubati con le
minacce la merendina e allora i casi
erano due o gli davi la merendina o
reagisci e io in quel caso ho preferito
la seconda ipotesi non ne sono fiero
non ne sono fiero sia chiaro però le
cose funzionavano così quando compì
sette anni era il 28 maggio del 1974 la
mamma gli aveva preparato una delle sue
meravigliose crostate da portare a
scuola
per festeggiare il mio compleanno con
gli altri bambini mattino quando mi
svegliai senti il profumo della torta
fatta la mamma sognavo già di andare a
scuola di giocare coi ragazzi e di
mangiare la torta in me non potevo
immaginare quel giorno di pioggia già
vedere la pioggia al mattino mi aveva
fatto ne avevamo parlato fastidio era il
giorno della strage di piazza loggia
quindi questo mio legame dolce amaro e
gioie dolori con brescia che mi
trascinerò credo nella tomba
nasce proprio da lì ma come il giorno
del mio compleanno
la mamma mi ha fatto persino la torta
fanno esplodere una bomba nel cuore
della mia città una ferita che tutt'oggi
è ancora aperta come lo infilata persino
nell'inno del brescia calcio la frase su
piazza loggia tanto è ancora viva in
quello quelle esperienze mi informai ma
cosa è successo sentivo le sirene
i vigili del fuoco i neofascisti hanno
messo una bomba in piazza loggia sono
morte delle persone dovete correre tutti
a casa non vi nascondo che la sera
stessa
diventai diventai chiesi la tessera
della resistenza da quel giorno insomma
non capivo ancora molto di politica ma
sicuramente questi signori avevano
rovinato la mia festa di compleanno e e
questo e segnerà anche poi le mie scelte
future sebbene io rimarrò anarchico
tutta la vita anche perché ho incontrato
uno dei miei giganti gino veronelli mio
maestro di vino e di anarchia al liceo
visto che alle mie alle medie mi ero
distinto ma non lo dico per falsa
modestia quella che per schopenhauer e
la scienza degli imbecilli dall'altro ma
lo dico perché è la verità non era
difficile distinguersi dai miei compagni
di classe erano tutti provenivano la
famiglia problematica insomma la cultura
non è che fosse come quella che vivevo
io in casa avevo sì la mamma che aveva
il diploma elementare ma papà insisteva
molto sul
da classicista quindi mi insegnava
sempre a leggere un libro mi parlava
dagli scrittori mi faceva apprezzare i
quadri quando quando eravamo in giro
sono ricchezze anche queste sono
ricchezze che che si possono godere con
gli occhi e che sono in italia
soprattutto abbiamo sotto gli occhi di
tutti i miei buoni voti consigliarono ai
miei genitori quando presi il diploma di
terza media della scuola tridentina di
urago mella di farmi fare il liceo
classico perché ero portato per le
lettere ero portato proprio a scrivere
tant'è che se facciamo un passo indietro
un brevissimo passo indietro che
nell'ultimo anno di asilo
io scrivevo già lo avevo imparato con un
gioco con dei cubi con le facce degli
animali che corrispondevano la lettera e
le suore convocarono mia madre dicendo a
lei che non erano d'accordo che non era
normale che non era giusto che un
bambino già all'asilo scrivesse e la
mamma gli sguardi ha imparato da solo
quindi ho capito da questi racconti di
mamma che ero molto portato verso la
parola la parola in effetti qui vedete
su questo schermo vedete le parole che
che rappresentano la mia vita insomma in
quali in un modo o nell'altro
majakovskij poeta dalla rivoluzione
russa straordinario artista colui che
scrisse dicendo che intingeva il pennino
della sua penna nel suo stesso sangue
vladimir majakovskij nella lettera al
compagno esenin commentando il suicidio
di quello che era un po il suo rivale in
poesia quello che rappresentava i tempi
passati dice che la parola e il
condottiero della forza umana
wow e allora io pensavo la parola è una
cosa molto importante e all'età di sei
anni la mia nonna la mia nonna nina chi
mi conosce sa che la mia chitarra lo
battezzata nina mi regalò una chitarrina
perché il bisnonno sebbene fosse un
operaio del cotonificio durante il
weekend aveva la passione della musica
suonava il clarinetto e chiamava sempre
qualcuno la nonna si metteva la chitarra
lui costruiva anche i mandolini sua
sorella al mandolino e facevano delle
feste incredibili
ecco perché con la musica allora non
siamo mai soli perché anche nella
povertà si possono trovare attimi di
convivialità qualcuno portava il
formaggio qualcuno portava una bottiglia
di vino anzi lo zio guido mi racconta
che a volte il bisnonno quando era su di
giri
amava farsi versare del vino nel
clarinetto direttamente poi partisse con
degli assolo incredibili ea me fa venire
menti bluesman americani che intingono
l'armonica nel bar bol
prima di suonarla e questo conferisce un
suono particolare e un po anche quello
spirito tipico dal blues quindi bb king
andava barbone il mio bisnonno giuseppe
a teroldego però l'effetto più o meno
era quella imparo immediatamente a
suonare e quando 15 16 anni arrivò al
ginnasio al liceo arnaldo di brescia
dove proprio come vicino di banco carlo
alberto il mio vicino di banco chi
suonava anche lui la chitarra insieme
fondano i timoria con i timoria facciamo
molta strada arrivammo a 23 22 23 anni
eravamo già sul palco di sanremo a
proporre la nostra musica e vincendo il
premio della critica ma soprattutto io
capii che la musica insieme alle parole
faceva nascere una canzone
è una canzone una piccola magia
un'epifania nasce sempre qualcosa di
nuovo e quindi iniziai a scrivere le
canzoni e il primo album lo intitola i
per la mia passione per per l'arte
colori che esplodono era dedicato a quei
pittori oa quei a quegli autori che
dicevano di contaminare la loro arte con
un'altra arte quindi vi faccio un
esempio pensate a van gogh quando nelle
straordinarie strazianti lettere al
fratello theo racconta l'arancione il
giallo per me sono accordi musicali mi
danno la serenità il nero che siamo i
suoi corvi e il colore del dolore è un
accordo minore
pensiamo a kandinsky alle sue
improvvisazioni lui a tantissimi quadri
chiamati improvvisazioni e numerati se
non sono un po le improvvisazioni del
jazz quello che amano tanto i jazz man e
oppure a quando
a quando tschaikowsky cercò di
descriverci con gli strumenti con la
musica
una mostra di quadri si intitola quadri
per un'esposizione pictures at an
exhibition e lui ci racconta con le note
questi quadri e ti sembra quasi di
vederli se chiudi gli occhi a quella la
contaminazione tra i generi artistici
diventerà la cifra del mio percorso che
sia quello che insegno indegnamente in
università a milano ai miei alunni o
quello che dico i miei figli o che metto
nelle mie canzoni
del resto questo percorso braccio a
braccio la pittura e la musica ce
l'hanno un po da sempre chi è in grado
di percepire certe sensibilità può anche
vedere della musica in un quadro dei
colori in una canzone
prendiamo uno dei quadri più famosi del
mondo eco non voglio andare in
territorio magari difficile
l'urlo di munch l'urlo di munch a me ha
sempre ricordato le canzoni
espressioniste per esempio della new
wave inglese una canzone dei cure di
robert smith
mi ricorda l'urlo di munch oppure il
post punk con le loro musiche spigolose
non vi ricordano forse le geometrie di
kirshner non vederli questi uomini madri
ma grimaldi anoressici di schiele non ci
ricordano forse il dark e addirittura
nella forma estetica della musica dark a
ecco un connubio che c'è da sempre se
vogliamo stare più sul sul semplice
pensiamo a fantasia di walt disney chi
non ha amato quel film dove già da
bambini potevamo capire che una musica
potesse essere raccontata da un cartone
animato e quindi questo percorso lo
portò avanti da sempre cercando di fare
andare a braccetto la musica la pittura
la poesia la letteratura
in questo percorso ho incontrato tanti
maestri tanti giganti come li chiamo in
questa in questa serie di parola dai
quali ho imparato qualcosa prima vi ho
accennato a gino veronelli chi era gino
gino era stato l'uomo l'uomo che ha dato
dignità al cibo e al vino in italia
prima di lui viene in italia erano
divisi tra rossi e bianchi poi è
arrivato lui un uomo che quando eravamo
seduti a tavola ti diceva prima di fare
l'esame olfattivo o visivo o degustativo
di un vino
penso alla fatica del contadino che c'è
dentro quel bicchiere oppure guarda
l'oste come maneggia la bottiglia da da
quel gesto quando ti servono un goccio
di vino tu puoi già capire l'amore o il
disamore che a quell'uomo per il suo
mestiere quindi per il mondo del vino
in fin dei conti come venne definito il
vino pavese piemontese quindi un uomo di
langa che parla spesso delle vigne
piemontesi cosa come potremmo definire
l'uva il vino ma io sostengo che il vino
siano le parole della terra che si fanno
vino quindi la parola anche della terra
e non soltanto la parola scritta e
andando avanti con gli anni somma o ho
imparato a parlare di questo poi ho dato
vita tante passioni e un contratto tanti
giganti ho incontrato sì sostengo la
causa del tibet perché il rock and roll
non è soltanto sesso droga e rock and
roll pensiamo a andy warhol e la sua
factory newyorkese dove arrivava lou
reed con i velvet underground nico e
fecero quel disco favoloso che tutti
quanti ricordiamo per quella banana
meravigliosa che dipinse warhol per i
velvet underground
poi il rock si trasformerà anche in in
attività sociale politica non partitica
non mi piace politica arriva a dylan
arriva joe strummer i diritti della
working class vengono cantati dalla
musica rock quindi ecco perché cerco di
farli capire quanto si debba uscire da
certi cliché magari più facili ai quali
è legata alla musica rock nella mia vita
nella mia vita un ruolo molto importante
hanno avuto le donne perché perché
negarlo sono sempre stato attratto e
affascinato dalla figura femminile forse
perché papà quando io ero adolescente si
trovò il benessere
purtroppo trovò anche un altro amore e
quindi lascio la mia mamma e io sono
cresciuto con mia madre della mia
sorellina ovviamente l'atmosfera non era
propriamente felice però io mi ero
perfettamente incarnato nella figura
dell'uomo di casa e poi da lì proprio
perché conosco le donne grazie grazie a
questa a questa casualità
ho anche apprezzato e qualche volta
sofferto dalle gioie e dolori
del mondo dell'amore ma soprattutto nel
mondo dell'amore nello spettacolo
frequentato talvolta delle donne famose
ahimè che si trascinavano senza volerlo
orde di paparazzi che sono stati uno dei
traumi più forti della mia vita
voi sapete che non appena ho preso il
premio della critica a sanremo nel 2004
hanno scoperto in me un male un male al
cuore congenito e ogni cinque anni devo
affrontare un'operazione pensate un po
che qui voglio farvi ridere che
abbandoniamo il libro cuore di de amicis
straordinario tra l'altro per un attimo
e grazie a una delle ultime operazioni
al cuore
ho incontrato veronica che era la figlia
di uno dei cardiochirurghi che mi ha
operato e l'ho sposata
quindi la figura della donna anche in un
momento così così drammatico mi ha
aiutato e mi ha dato conforto e amore
siccome soffro e patiscono ancora oggi
le attenzioni le attenzioni di un certo
tipo di stampa radio di cronaca rosa
quest'anno io veronica abbiamo deciso
nonostante questo mm
della mia orta che mi separa da da
un'altra operazione quindi io sto
vivendo sapendo che quando la mia volta
si allargherà di un millimetro dovrò
correre in ospedale prima che faccia
esplodere il mio cuore però ecco avere
questa spada di damocle sulla testa
adesso non voglio esagerare non sono
nemmeno il presidente degli stati uniti
quindi non mi fermero cazzata del genere
non è stata una benedizione però trovo
che sia stata anche una fortuna perché
mi dà la possibilità di apprezzare la
vita ogni giorno e se qualcuno pensa che
la vita sia breve potrebbe trovare in
seneca nel de brevitate vitae le parole
che vi sto dicendo la vita breve impiega
male il suo tempo altrimenti la vita non
è vero io ho imparato a vivere ogni
giorno come fosse l'ultimo
e a imparare a conoscere a vivere come
se non dovessimo morire mai
quindi non meravigliatevi se voglio
dividere con voi che considero amici
siamo nella mia città una bella notizia
ma vorrei visto che la spada di damocle
ce l'abbiamo sulla testa a tutti la mia
soltanto un crine un po più fine di
quello del vostro probabilmente ma
nemmeno questo mi permetterà mai di
perdere fiducia nella vita e la prova ne
è questa
[Applauso]